uh green juice for bloating
hey one I'm Abby sharp welcome to Abby's
kitchen
[Music]
in today's video we'll be taking a look
at Canadian lifestyle YouTuber Fernanda
Ramirez and as usual you can pause the
screen or look at the description to
check out my disclaimer including a
trigger warning to those with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating so as always please feel free to
skip this video if it's not supportive
to your journey and if you are not
already subscribed here please hit that
subscribe button and don't forget to
follow me on Tick Tock and Instagram at
Abby's kitchen so today we're going to
be taking a little look-see at Fernandez
what I eat in a day video which she
titled realistic easy and healthy meal
ideas plus how I fixed my gut health
aesthetic what does aesthetic mean in
this context like someone make the
sentence makes sense anyways maybe I'm
just too old for this [ __ ] but let's get
into it I feel like recently I've been a
lot better at cooking for myself and
choosing foods that actually make me
feel good and haven't been damaging my
gut I honestly think that I've really
helped my health and I've been feeling a
lot less bloated and overall energy for
the day so it's unclear Fernanda has a
diagnosed digestive disorder or if there
are just certain trigger foods that
might be causing her some mild bloating
but either way bloating is a valid
Health concern however I just want to
clarify that there are very few
circumstances where Foods would actually
damage your gut if you're Celiac and you
eat gluten then yes you might be
damaging the lining of your gut however
with most other intolerances we might
see some mild inflammation with
consumption but generally speaking if
you start small and work your way up you
can retrain your gut to tolerate those
foods without damage also bloating on
its own is not necessarily a symptom of
a damaged gut it is normal for your gut
to expand and contract throughout the
day and it's also perfectly normal to
experience mild bloating after certain
types of foods but if the bloating you
experience becomes frequent painful and
accompanied by other Digest of symptoms
then it's probably best to consult with
Healthcare professional to rule out
digestive disorders I also have a whole
video on the common causes of bloating
and what to do about it which you can
watch right here for vitamins I just
make sure that I'm for sure taking
biotin collagen some sort of a
probiotics for your digestive health
honestly I've been doing this probably
for the past two months and I've really
really seen the difference I also like
to take vitamin D so first of all while
I am a dietitian and of course we
encourage getting as much nutrition from
food as possible I also am a supporter
of supplements if they help to take the
stress out of eating especially if you
have other clinical conditions
intolerances allergies Etc which can
present dietary gaps so let's talk about
fernanda's non-negotiable supplements
first of all taking a daily vitamin D
supplement is definitely a good daily
practice for most people especially for
us Canadians who maybe don't get
consistent sun exposure year round and
since sunscreen is recommended pretty
much everywhere this isn't exclusively a
Canadian problem vitamin D3 isn't in a
whole lot of Whole Foods either so I do
think that this is One supplement that
most people can benefit from usually at
least a thousand IUS but a lot of people
may need a lot more now probiotics can
also be helpful for a lot of people but
it's also important to be mindful of the
strain as not all probiotics are made
equal and some products could
potentially worsen digestive symptoms
insensitive folks most research suggests
that multi-strain probiotic supplements
containing lactobacillus and
bifidobacterium are generally your best
bet for bloating but it's still best to
rule out other digestive disorders
before starting any probiotic regimen
and then there's collagen which is a
protein that's been shown to have
multiple benefits in the body however
our bodies can actually make collagen
from any dietary protein and vitamin C
rich foods and while the research on
supplementing is more convincing for
things like joint bone health and maybe
skin Health it's still in its infancy
for hair and nails which let's be honest
is why most young women tend to use it
there's a lot of research on this
underway but I'm still waiting to be
convinced that collagen protein is any
more Superior than a less expensive
protein powder or food-based protein for
most healthy folks today I opted for a
green juice though I have a juicer and
it's been honestly a really great
addition into my morning routine it's
just a whole process it's a whole ritual
it's fun to like cut up your vegetables
it's fun to make it it tastes really
good and you know that it's good for you
and it's a way to get in vegetables and
fruits if you don't regularly eat that
much my favorite type of juice is
normally lemon cucumber celery apples
and ginger so I appreciate that Fernanda
highlights the things that she genuinely
enjoys about preparing green juice that
go beyond its alleged health benefits so
she says she enjoys the fun ritual The
Taste getting in her veggies all of
which are valid reasons to enjoy just
about anything regardless of any bogus
Wellness claims and while Juiced fruit
and veggies are a great way to get in a
quick dose of micronutrients it's worth
noting that juicing strips produce of
its beneficial fiber and if we want to
talk gut health which I'm pretty sure is
the underlying theme of this video fiber
is kind of King fiber is important for
improving regularity and maintaining gut
microbiome diversity among a ton of
other non-gut related benefits also
folks with particularly sensitive
digestive systems might actually find
that some juices actually exacerbate
their symptoms especially because they
often contain higher concentrations of
high FODMAP fruits and veggies so for
instance this particular juice would be
considered a high FODMAP juice given
that it contains apple and several
stalks of celery some folks with
sensitive guts will respond to excess
fodmaps with bloating and constipation
and for others the pendulum will swing
in the opposite direction and cause the
runs and I think sometimes influencers
conflate clearing themselves out with
helping their digestion but it's
actually the opposite of helpful long
term because chronically loose stools
can disrupt the microbiome and wipe out
beneficial species of bacteria now I
have no idea what her poops look like
obviously so this is just a gentle
reminder that gut health is super
complex and individualized so something
like a green juice may help or hinder
different folks on their respective gut
health Journeys for the past like two
months I've been kind of intermittent
fasting just eating at 12. this hasn't
been hard for me at all because normally
I do yoga or workout in the morning if
I'm going to be doing a very harsh
impact activity like maybe doing a
cycling class or doing heavy weight
lifting I'll always have banana before I
go so technically it's not intermittent
fasting if she's having green juice
before noon but not that that really
matters anyways I'm just kind of
pointing out how dumb most of these diet
labels actually are now I'm not going to
go too far deep into the world of
intermittent fasting because I have beat
that horse to death but when it comes to
gut health specifically there may be
some benefits for helping to facilitate
the migratory Motor complex and I don't
think we really need to call this
intermittent fasting as it doesn't
really need to be any kind of natural
aggressive fast but there can be some
benefit for some people to having like a
solid 12 hours overnight and four to
five hours between meals it does seem
that this is just kind of like an eating
pattern that works for Fernanda and I
appreciate that she'll just add in some
extra carbs before a workout love that
flexibility my mom made these powerful
s right now I
I this is actually my second one
so what's unclear why Fernanda shouldn't
be eating these powerballs like maybe
her mom made them for herself and
they're off limits to the rest of the
family I don't know or maybe she feels
like she can't eat them because the
clock hasn't struck noon yet or perhaps
she's intentionally restricting them
because they are a higher calorie snack
she didn't say and so I will not
speculate but I do think we need to be
careful with statements like this
especially with younger audiences who
may quickly assume that a nutrient-dense
snack like a yummy Powerball should be
something that they should avoid or feel
guilty about eating and if it is to
maintain a longer fast for gut health
aka the migratory Motor complex it's
worth pointing out that the green juice
already kind of kiboshed that plan so I
really see no harm in having a few balls
that's what she said so I started to
cook for myself more I've been more
mindful about what I'm actually putting
in my body or like how much oil and salt
I'm using so something that I love to
use is a spray oil and I've also decided
to opt for assault free seasonings these
taste so good they taste the exact same
as regular seasoning but they're salt
free which is great because I've
definitely been trying to lower my
sodium intake I feel like for a while
there I was eating out so much and I was
just having so much sodium that like I
look bloated all the time as I'm cooking
I'm just making sure that I drink water
throughout the entire day that'll also
help flush any extra sodium you have in
your body only downside says you have to
go pee like every five minutes I think
it's important to distinguish between
bloating from digestive distress and
bloating from water retention because
these are two very different things with
different corresponding protocols so it
is true that sodium can increase water
retention which might make you feel
temporarily a little more puffy and that
is a lot more likely to happen from
consuming a lot of ultra processed foods
then assuming a lot of homemade meals
that are seasoned at home unless you
have a clinical condition like kidney
disease or high blood pressure where
your doctor has ordered like a low salt
diet I don't think that we really need
to stress much about seasoning our food
during cooking or using only salt free
seasonings especially for an active
young woman not getting enough salt
actually can cause things like headaches
muscle weakness confusion and nausea so
it can be a really delicate balance and
it seems to me that there might be a
combination of factors at play in the
bloating from a lot of takeout food and
some of those factors might not be such
a big issue when cooking balanced meals
at home so she feels better cutting back
great you do you but for most of you
watching I don't think that salt free
seasonings are necessary when eating
mostly at home as for her oil tip if you
prefer the convenience of like an even
Spritz of cooking spray you do you again
but just know that those oil sprays are
not actually calorie free as the
marketing often suggests they actually
have the same amount of calories as the
oil that you pour it's just that food
manufacturers can label it as being
calorie free if the serving size is
small enough so if you were to actually
spray your pan for like three to four
seconds you're looking at around 30 or
so calories nothing to be concerned
about obviously but you could also just
put some really good quality extra
virgin olive oil on like a piece of
paper towel or a dish towel and then
wipe it around the pan for the same
amount and that leads me to a quick pep
talk on oil fear mongering in general
yes oil is high in calories and fat but
we need some fats in our diet and smart
use of cooking oils is not a hazard to
our health if you want a more in-depth
breakdown on the research on oils you
can watch my video right here alright
moving on
[Music]
okay she's done she looks a little bit
dull for some reason I'm actually really
into this breakfast hash slash scramble
situation that we got going on we got
some protein and fat in the eggs we got
carbs fiber and micronutrients in the
potatoes and veggies and fruit super
simple and low fuzz it might be a bit of
a lighter meal for most of us like
considering that it's already 12 o'clock
so I would totally say that we could
throw in some toast with some Nut Butter
just for some extra protein carbs and
fat okay guys I'm in my car now it's
actually 3 P.M and this is normally the
time when I would have lunch but I'm
honestly feeling so low energy I need a
little pick-me-up so I need to run some
errands at the mall right now and I
think I'm actually gonna pick up a
coffee listen I [ __ ] love coffee but
I don't recommend it in the afternoon
just to like fill a void for a few key
reasons first of all let's get something
straight coffee doesn't actually give us
true energy calories do and needing
caffeine in the afternoon every day is
generally a good sign that something
isn't nutritionally optimal we probably
actually needed more calories to get us
through to that next meal and a lot of
us have grown up using caffeine to mask
or blunt legitimate hunger cues so I get
that it might feel like it's a bit of a
habit to reach for coffee instead of a
snack but I would suggest exploring a
hunger crushing combo here or trying a
larger midday meal to get us to that
lunch meal with good stable energy
levels caffeine in the afternoon can
also interfere with good sleep quality
since its Half-Life is about four to six
hours so some experts actually suggest
cutting yourself off as early as 10
hours before you want to go to bed
everyone's metabolism of caffeine will
vary so do experiment with the timing
for you that feels best it's been a few
hours later but I came back from the
mall I got ready I did a meeting filmed
some tick tocks you know how it is look
a lot better than I did this morning but
I am starving now that coffee actually
really brightened my energy up yeah I'm
not surprised at all
like more evidence why a calorie Rich
snack was likely what the body actually
craved I honestly put a little bit more
on my plate than I assume I'll eat but
sometimes I say that and I end up eating
the whole thing here is what the final
Bowl looks like as we saw earlier my
avocado is a little bit hard but it
looks so good I've actually never even
made chickpeas before so I'm really
excited I gotta be honest if I was
starving like Fernanda apparently
claimed she was I would not have made it
through all of this meal prep with all
of those steps involved I probably
wouldn't have even made it through if I
wasn't starving because her breakfast
meal was already pretty labor intensive
like does anyone else not have time to
cook like this more than once a day
I mean if I'm chopping potatoes at
breakfast I am not chopping sweet
potatoes four hours later again for
lunch but anyways just me I mean kudos
to Fernanda for the commitment I am
jealous and also impressed as for the
lunch itself this hunger crushing combo
in this recipe is working overtime and
we love to see it we're getting a double
dose of healthy fast from the tahini and
avocado double dose of protein from the
chickpeas and quinoa and a mega dose of
fiber from basically everything else yes
to this lunch it looks like such a
winner was craving something sweet for
dessert so I'm eating this little lemon
biscotti
so it's totally common to crave
something sweet after a Savory meal even
if you feel physically full since we
have multiple types of hunger that we
typically need to satisfy so stomach
hunger is the physical sensation of
needing to eat heart hunger is driven by
our emotions and then mouth hunger is a
craving for a specific sensory aspect of
food all three types of hunger are
completely valid and deserve to be
tended to without guilt fullness is a
lot more than just physical satiety it's
emotional satisfaction as well and
constantly ignoring mouth hunger often
just results in a binge so it's good
practice to be aware of the types of
hunger that are in the driver's seat and
to approach our food decisions with
awareness but not judgment here she is
so easy I've got a little bit of rice
and then my veggies and of course my
protein it just looks so good this
dinner is checking all of my boxes it's
beautifully colorful it's easy to
prepare hair and it's balanced with
healthy fats and protein from the salmon
carbs from the rice and fiber and
micronutrients from the veggies so to
sum this up I think banana has done a
great job meeting her nutritional needs
with three balanced meals and a few
snacks in her day I also appreciate that
even though she considers herself to be
an intermittent faster it didn't result
in her skipping an entire meal but
rather she just kind of like shifted her
calories later on in the day which it
just seems like that's what works for
her I will just say that I don't think
we need to reinforce diet Culture by
like naming our way of eating anything
in particular especially because in her
case it wasn't even like that accurate I
could also probably do without the
restrictive language related to oils
salt and snacking in general and I know
that these are trendy Wellness rules
that are just like all around us so
she's likely learning them online just
like the rest of us but this is just a
friendly reminder to stay critical of
the content that you consume even if it
comes from your favorite Wellness
influencers because what might be
working for them may not work for you
and on that note that's all that I have
for you guys today if you like this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below with who or
what you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]